what's all your firsts
all the first you guys man we'll be in
here all day youtube
then your top ten first that's you give
me five you know you got that credit for
man
on the first rapper on youtube okay on
the first rapper on twitch
on the first rapper to get signed
straight off the internet from high
school to a record deal
to jimmy iveen and underscore records
for over a million dollars
man stop playing with me what i'm the
first [ __ ] to
do all type of [ __ ] let them know
on the first [ __ ] i'm the first [ __ ]
to write
and produce a song at 16 and go number
one on the billboard hot 100 for however
many months it was
i forgot the other girl name who did it
it was a girl i don't even know her name
nobody never did that
these [ __ ] don't make their own beats
they got producers
i made the beat and i rapped on the song
and i recorded engineered it at my house
in the crib in the bedroom
facts and then flew out here with y'all
lit and met with jimmy i mean
interscope with my feet kicked up with a
million dollars from high school 16
nobody never did that nobody that's fair
on the first first instagram badges
where you can go live on instagram and
get paid and make money from it
um